for days protests have brought Bolivia's
largest city to a standstill
the unrest in Santa Cruz was triggered
by government plans to delay a census
until 2024.
[Music]
streets have been closed and public
transport and teaching in schools
suspended indefinitely
police were called in to break up
fighting between demonstrators opposing
the government and those who support it
they're trying to attack us look at me
this is all I have that's it but
pro-government supporters are armed with
stones
Santa Cruz's Bolivia's economic
Powerhouse
it's mostly conservative which puts it
at odds with the liberal government of
President Luis Arcee
this leaders say the results of the
census would enable much-needed funds to
reach the city's 2 million people
we want better quality of life the
census is carried out every 10 years if
there is no census there is no progress
in health education or infrastructure
our region is growing but we are being
left behind
foreign
but it may not all be about money some
believe those supporting the senses
wanted to be taken in 2023 so results
will be available two years later when
national elections are scheduled and
that could lead to more seats in
Parliament and more influence across the
Santa Cruz region
while protesters call for more strikes
the president has called for calm
the government says holding the census
in 2024 will de-politicize the process
and ensure a higher degree of accuracy
critics are skeptical
Katya Lopez Al Jazeera